what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and today Marvel has
shifted a lot of dates in phase six
actually phase five and six but
unfortunately we're going to have to
wait until phase six to get some of
these movies that we were going to be
getting in Phase five now before
everybody starts to freak out I don't
think that this is a huge deal yes it
sucks that we have to wait a little bit
longer for certain projects which of
course we're about to dive into but I
think this is primarily due to all of
the issues that blade has been having if
you're not aware it's been recently
announced that production on blade is on
hold sadly the new blade project
recently lost its director also
mahershala Ali recently came out and
expressed frustration about the script
how there are only two fight scenes and
they're pretty lackluster as he
described them meaning they're not
really anything special so due to this
they also lost the writer and apparently
they they are starting directly from
scratch a completely new story a
completely new script and according to
today's reports production is completely
on hold for blade until they find a new
director that most likely caused the
pushback for all of these other dates
because of course blade is one of the
movies that got pushed back so let's
dive into which four movies have been
pushed back now so speaking of Blade
originally blade was supposed to come
out on November 3rd of 2023 in Phase 5
however now it is coming out on
September 6th of
2024. so Blake got pushed back almost an
entire year but like I mentioned it
really does need that pushback they need
more time we don't want to have a
lackluster blade movie we want a great
blade movie now sadly there were some
other casualties as well and Deadpool 3
with Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman was
one of them however luckily for us it
was not pushed back too much it was
originally supposed to come out on
September 6th of 2024 and now it is
coming out on November 8th of 2024 so
not like it was pushed back a year we
only have to wait two extra months which
is bad news but also good news that it
wasn't delayed a year now the next two
delayed dates are of course really sad
as well the next one that was pushed
back was the Fantastic Four originally
Marvel's first family was supposed to
debut early November of 2024.
unfortunately it has now been pushed
back to February 14th of 2025 so we have
a little bit over a five month delay for
the Fantastic Four and the last one to
be delayed and this is rather sad is
Avengers Secret Wars Now Avengers Secret
Wars was originally supposed to come out
early November of 2025 however
unfortunately now it is going to be
released on May 1st of
2026. sadly that is just about a seven
month delay okay now fortunately for us
all of the other projects in Phase 5 and
phase six they are the same so Avengers
the King Dynasty that movie is still
going to release in May of 2025. so as
far as we know for right now at least
these four movies blade Deadpool 3 The
Fantastic Four and Avengers Secret Wars
are the only movies that have been
pushed back hopefully it stays this way
and no other films are going to be
delayed as well but again keep in mind
that some of these delays are typically
good things again blade is being delayed
because it wasn't that good in the first
place and we don't want a bad movie
especially a big Supernatural movie like
blade so it's safe to assume that if
Marvel is pushing back movies it's
usually because they're trying to make
something really good so yes this does
suck and yes we have to wait a little
bit longer for some of these amazing
movies coming out but at least Marvel
Studios is doing what they have to do to
make great movies so that is good but
hey let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on all the latest MCU news
and for live updates you can follow me
on Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching wolf wolf